diese vor
[Musik]
hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu one is jut
und heute kommt endlich das video auf
dass hier alle gewartet haben denn die
spannend brauche ich nicht mehr meine
zähne sind gerade wow das ist doch schön
herr bin so glücklich dass ich damals
dazu entschieden habe mit seinen zwei
zusammen
meine szene gerade zu machen ich muss
unbedingt das letzte video auch noch mal
anschauen um keine punkte zu vergessen
ich habe ja so viele produkte
ausprobiert und auch über die letzten
monate so oft genutzt und ich muss
wirklich umfassend jetzt alles zu einem
fazit bring you tief wenn du dein
eigenes video suchen muss wer seine
haare auf einem kanal jetzt aus und
thema geworden sind ja leute ich war in
köln und hab sie mir absteigen lassen
ich wollte eigentlich ein video drehen
ich dachte weil ich sie auch eigentlich
schon kurz machen wollte dass ich ein
video drehe ich kopiere kellys frisur
aber dann hatte die frisörin prise sind
friseurin oh mein gott da herr cage
nicht so lange zeit dann habe ich sagen
okay machen scheiß drauf die klicks
schade aber kann man nix machen
natürlich kurze haare
also wenn die szene war ja wirklich in
ordnung bevor ich die spange benutzt
habe sie die waren halt nicht perfekt
gerade aber wenn ich das jetzt wäre es
schon irgendwie kraft kurz und eine ganz
kleine ist okay gut dass ich schon
angefangen und über meine ziele zu
sprechen denn das ist auch das erste
thema im video mein retter sunshine 2
die ganzen spangen habe ich benutzt und
irgendwie aufbewahrt ich konnte sie
nicht wegschmeißen für alle die das
erste video nicht gesehen haben ist hans
meyer bietet einen service an für
unsichtbare zahnspangen weiß anscheinend
mal bekommt man alle sprangen direkt
zugeschickt nachdem man den abdruck
gemacht hat und muss sie dann alle zwei
wochen wechselt meine behandlung habe
ich ein paar wochen beendet ich bin
jetzt quasi fertig und super happy
und jetzt habe ich meine erste spange
gefunden wenn ich mir anschaue wie meine
zähne waren es ist ein komisches gefühl
irgendwie weiß ist ein bisschen eklig
habt ihr aber sauber gemacht keine sorge
das war halt so dass dieser zahn war
komplett drin
die beiden waren viel zu sehr nach außen
und ja einfach jetzt gerade zähne
ich habe mich halt mittlerweile so an
meine geraden szene gewöhnt dass wenn
ich jetzt auch die spannung angucke auch
jetzt für den unterkiefer des wahrheit
vorne wo stehe ich eine vorderen szene
waren sie nach innen gedreht und der
linke war noch so ein bisschen über den
anderen wenn man sich dann jetzt so das
ist meine letzte zum beispiel du bist
heute besonders am anfang der behandlung
habe ich mir immer die schienen
angeguckt dann später übertragen werde
und habe dann immer schon gedacht das
ist so gerade als auch meine zähne so
gerade werden können
und wenn ich jetzt diese alten schied
anschauen die sozis sind ja noch gerade
so
werbe video aller zeiten echte emotionen
und weil glück sich verdoppelt wenn man
es teilt habe ich jetzt sogar was für
euch 20 prozent auf das abdruck sechs
bis acht cent wird euch nach hause
geschickt und dann müssen wir also zwei
sachen zusammen kneten drauf beißen und
dann haben wir halt einen abdruck von
euren szenen und der ist dafür da um
erstmal zuschauen ist man für die
behandlung geeignet oder also kann man
das lösen mit den schienen und dann hat
man auch gleich ein abdruck und darauf
werden dann diese schienen gemacht mit
dem 3d drucker die zukunft natürlich
spielt geld hier eine rolle und zwar
kostet die ganze prozedur 1899 euro
aber ihr bekommt mit meinem rabattcode
mal seine 100 euro geschenkt und wenn
ihr das geld nicht gerade so unter der
couch liegen habt dann könnt ihr auch
eine ratenzahlung machen bis zu 48
monaten und zum thema zähne bleibt mir
eigentlich nichts anderes zu sagen außer
mega haben wir super guide to normal
weiter mit der hautpflege
ok warum sich die leute daran ich kann
irgendwie kurze haare und diese gut
steilen kaykin 12 was soll ich zu diesem
gerät sagen ist absolut sinnvoll sich so
was zu holen
das ist gut für alle toten
hautschüppchen so genießt man es sollte
vorsicht angewendet werden also nicht zu
doll reimen davon habe ich immer echt
rhythmen bekommen und ja sonst zur wache
ihr findet natürlich alle produkte unten
verlinkt das nächst auf unserer liste
doktor dennis gross so mein gott nach
sechs monaten dann denke ich erst dass
man es hier laufen kommen kann
was hat so cool aus gesehen wie ihr seht
ist es nach sechs monaten noch nicht
verbraucht das liegt aber nicht daran
dass es nicht wirkt sondern dass ich so
sparsam damit bin das sind so anti aging
bier tücher fürs gesicht die wirklich
sehr gut funktionieren ich weiß nicht
was sie so mit der haut machen aber sie
fühlt sich danach reihen an und ich habe
schon das gefühl sind anti aging effekt
zu merken die dinger kosten halt 80 euro
und deswegen hab ich's halt nicht so oft
angewendet wie man es vielleicht
anwenden sollte das ist das polnische
herrn und der größte minuspunkt ist
natürlich umweltfreundlichkeit ist hier
auf jeden fall nicht gegeben
das ist der hohe anwendung sind es 12
tücher und halt die verpackung finde ich
nicht so stark bleiben wir bei doktor
dennis die maske
[Musik]
vielleicht liegt es daran dass ich noch
nicht so alt bin dass mir meine kleinen
supermini kleinfeldchen nichts ausmachen
aber ich war von der anwendung jetzt
nicht so begeistert und ja wenn man
irgendwie noch nicht so ein problem mit
seinen augen partien hat dann werde ich
mich da auch nicht jeden abend hinsetzen
und das machen wären blöd seine zeit
damit zu bestrafen sie sehr futuristisch
ist
ich denk mal nice to have irgendwann
wird es bei mir nämlich anfangen dann
sage ich führe mein gott mein gewicht
das ist so faltig und dann mache ich den
hier und dann hoffe ich dass es nach
einer sekunde wieder weg ist 238 hat die
gekostet
vielleicht gebe ich sie meiner schwester
auf jetzt schon befinde älter ist jetzt
komplett bei der dekadenz angekommen
denn wir sind beim vorher vor jetzt
jetzt kommen wir voran das ganze jetzt
kommt etwas ganz ganz neues das ist ein
vibrations- wärme teil für gesichts
machten und gibt es eine lange zeit
nicht benutzt weil ich knauserig bin und
keine gesichtsmasken dafür kaufen wollte
eine packung kostet 20 euro und hat 7
behandlungen leider muss ich aber sagen
das ist die beste gesichtsbehandlung die
ich jemals gemacht habe kollegin neid
ist auf jeden fall mein favorit und
immer wenn ich diese maske benutzer habe
ich am nächsten tag wirklich die beste
haut sie strahlt sie ist voll
ja sieht einfach gut aus es sind
verschiedene arten glow addicks dann
leuchtet man kollidiert wie gesagt dass
benutzt man abends zur beruhigung dann
gibt es noch die hütte ration wasser
braucht man und antipolnischen aber ich
glaube so gegen rötungen und so und es
kommt leute etwas und einfach mal gerade
maske benutzen die make my day an machen
jetzt muss man so den barcode
fotografieren
macht man hier dringend auf blut war
stoffe teilen sie mit leichten
kreisenden bewegungen die masken essenz
gleichmäßig auf gesicht und hals
ich glaube es kommt aus südkorea
entspannen sie sich
während das grüne led licht ihnen einen
helleren gleichmäßigeren photon schenkt
der link ganzen
einen helleren hautton wird kommt aus
korea leute hast sich immer gut an
verpflichtend ändern und das echt immer
sehr viel dreck vom sich also wenn ihr
einfach mal so 280 euro herumliegen habt
dann könnt ihr euch dieses ding holen
store italien für das nächste produkt
140 euro gehen ich war in köln und auf
dem rückflug wurde mir meine la mer
creme abgenommen weil mein
durchsichtiger beutel in der diese la
mer creme drin war
und übrigens noch andere sachen der
beute war ein bisschen zu groß und sie
sagte ja es darf er nur für den liter
sein und es war ein liter beutel
er war war flach und länger als normale
liter beutel aber das volumen verändert
sich ja nicht wenn das war die
geschichte zu meiner la mer creme hat
mir nicht gefallen und sah 80 euro la
mer kandidat zum gesicht reinigen kann
gerne von euch jemand haben weil davon
kriege ich einfach pickel und ich muss
auch sagen die la mer creme habe ich
auch ein paar wochen benutzt und die hat
mir auch nicht gefallen
also so gar nicht also auch nicht so 150
euro creme mein gesicht sieht so gut aus
dafür habe ich aber eine ganz klare
empfehlung die enzyme und creme von la
schicht ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig
aber sie ist der hammer ich finde keine
creme macht es so fresh das gesicht und
meist ist und es ist sogar teil mit der
verpackung dass man sie wieder abgeben
kann und johannes 19 euro auch ein
bisschen teuer aber immerhin keine 140
die nächsten produkte waren das wimpern
serum und augenbrauen serum und ich muss
euch sagen ich weiß nicht mal gerade wo
es liegt ich habe es ein paar wochen
benutzt aber ich habe einfach nicht
daran geglaubt und wenn man ein produkt
nicht glaubt dann funktioniert es auch
meine wimpern
ich habe noch überlegt ob ich meine
wimpern für dieses video auffüllen
lassen
dann dachte ich aber das geht ja voll
gegen das prinzip des videos weil ich
wollte ja die innere schönheit strahlen
lassen
und so aufgeklebten wimpern haben jetzt
nicht viel mit innerer schönheit zu tun
ich benutze eigentlich zurzeit nur die
wimpern von hertie um quasi diese
voluminösen tollen wimpern zu haben ganz
viele von euch haben mich auch in
letzter zeit gefragt woher meine wimpern
sind weil ich sie jetzt öfter mal
getragen haben sind von love in
kooperation mit htc schmidt hatte
schmidt hat tisch mit hey leute die
muttis back on track mit dem härtesten
steht
es gibt aber ich sein buhl und berlin
und das sind die berlin
und ich habe berlin genommen weil die
ein bisschen weniger krass ausgesehen
haben und ich das unbedingt mal
ausprobieren wollte und dann habe ich
sie aufgemacht und sie sind einfach also
lege mir am arsch
die sind riesig hier mag die verpackung
von gerne man hat das gefühl sie so
ordentlich zu machen und sein make-up
einzupacken und bei den anderen ist es
immer so und dieses conditioner sich
dafür 100 euro gekauft habe es war so
eine geldverschwendung dieses produkt
hat überhaupt nichts gutes für meine
haare getan die haben sich so trocken
und blöder nach immer angefühlt dass ich
das auch einfach dann beim umzug
tatsächlich in möglichen habe auch ins
weh getan hat aber wenn etwas nicht gut
für euch ist liebe marie konto davids
park neu dass man jetzt kommt noch eine
extraportion auch wenn ihr sie nicht
hören wollt für die augen bin und sich
zurzeit klinik und das ist so
[Musik]
das ist halt damit die augen irgendwie
schön feucht und strahlen sind und so
finde ich gut und von klinik habe ich
mir auch eine gesichtsreinigung seite
geholt und die ist viel besser als die
von la mer also mehr empfehlen
wert diese creme hilft mir super gegen
rötungen also wenn ich eine zeitlang
sehr rote haut habe dann nehme ich die
duh craig l usd estate skins mit madness
ins game face hat mir richtig gut
geholfen ohne witz jetzt und ich muss
sagen gericht ein bisschen nachlässig
was sinn machen würde weil was das
ziemlich und essig hilft gegenteil make
up hätte ich niemals geht das sage aber
macpherson body foundation absolut wenig
deckend aber gibt dieser haut auch so
einen strahlenden feuchtigkeit effekt
ich mag es einfach nicht wenn man so
matt ist ich finde eine glänzende haut
auch wenn sie ein bisschen öl ich es
finde ich immer schöner als dieses
perfekt ab mattierte gesicht weil das ja
vielleicht auch ein bisschen natürlicher
ist aber ich finde es
ariana grande auch wenn sie jetzt von
tomaten angeschwollenen hals bekommen
hat die hat immer so ein genie face und
ist doch egal ob es möglich ist oder
dings also ja und jetzt kommt das letzte
produkt fürs gesicht mitesser ausdrücke
das hab ich mir bei amazon bestellt das
sind so schlaufen die man über mitesser
legt und dann runter zieht und das
drückt quasi den mitesser aus ohne dass
man mit seinen bakterien händen da die
ganze zeit so rom mit das muss man
natürlich an auch das infizieren oder
sauber machen wie ihr das auch machen
wollte aber ist wirklich sehr gut und
man hat auch nicht dieses gesicht am
ende es ist einfach reiner und
funktioniert besser
und last but not least meine haase sie
hasst die reise mit meinem haar nichts
mitbekommen ich habe sie zweimal
entfärbt und dann habe sie einmal rot
färben lassen was ein die strawberry
blond werden sollte aber dann doch roth
war
jetzt sind wieso strawberry blond oder
dunkeln
also jetzt habe ich einfach blonde
rötliche strähnen und es gab so zwei
gründe warum ich sie jetzt kurz machen
ließ einmal meine haare waren komplett
kaputt von dem ganzen blondieren und
entfernen und färben und so was ich mag
aber tatsächlich auch kurze haare bei
mir lieber also jetzt so ungeschminkt
und so finde ich keine frisur mit recht
machen und so dann mag ich eigentlich
kurze haare lieber weil sie sich auch
halt immer gesünder anfühlen als diese
lang dinger diese unten noch rumhängen
und versuchen gut auszusehen und wegen
dem blondieren benutze ich all blacks
nummer sechs bond smuda das hab ich mir
beim friseur auf quatschen lassen aber
es macht die haare sehr griffig
ich habe einfach das gefühl sie eine
gute pflege über da ist halt so dass
wenn man mit rollerblades pflegen möchte
dann musste es auch mit urlaub lex
aufgehellt worden sein das weiß ich
nicht ich glaube meine haare wurden
nicht mit einer flex aufgehellt meine
wunden glaube ich erlösung aber trotzdem
macht das schön glänzend vertritt
irgendwas muss ich auf jeden fall gerade
richtig machen denn meine haut gefällt
mir extrem gut ich fühle mich total wohl
in meiner haut liegt auch echt an den
zähnen an mein bewusstsein für meinen
körper
ich fühle mich wohl in meinem gewicht
ich mich stören wählen und cellulite und
alles stört mich zurzeit nicht ist
glaube ich auch vielleicht frühling
würde ich alles noch einmal genauso
machen ja ich bin sehr happy mit allem
dieses experiment hat tatsächlich mein
komplettes verhältnis zu beautyprodukten
geändert da hab ich bin ich jetzt so auf
diese maske gekommen auf gesichts
bürsten auf pflegeprodukte für die haare
haut pflegeprodukte augen dings also ich
habe so ein bisschen bin ich bin wieso
nicht schwimmern dieses becken rhein
geschwommen von beauty produkten und hab
echt schwimmen gelernt und merkel jetzt
so wenn man ein bisschen was für sein
äußeres tut fühlt man sich redlich wohl
natürlich keine anleitung für euch dass
ihr jetzt unbedingt geld ausgeben müsste
für irgendwelche produkte nur damit ihr
euch besser eure haut fühlt aber das ist
halt thema des videos und
deswegen kann ich das jetzt auch so
sagen ich fühle mich besser mit konsum
in mein gesicht okay leute das war's
jetzt auch danke das dann schon mal für
die kooperation es hat mir sehr viel
spaß gemacht und an euch alle da draußen
peace out